Çeviri: Ahmet Asliyuce
Gözden geçirme: Orkun Nazim Kadioglu
Salona bakar mısınız?
Muhteşem, herkes genç.
Muhteşemsiniz bir kez, onu söyleyeyim.
Gençler, inanılmaz.
Burayı niye doldurdunuz?
Bu salona niye geldiniz?
Sabahın köründe kalkıp buraya
gelmenizin bir anlamı var,
bir amacı var, içinizde bir tutku var.
Ne olduğunu bilmiyorsunuz yalnız.
İçinizde bir heyecan var.
İçinizde bir şeyi öğrenme,
bir şeye farklı bakma,
bir şeyi farklı bir şekilde değerlendirme
ama bir silkinip üzerinizden o bıkkınlığı,
o sıkkınlığı bir atma isteği var.
Ben bu isteği bildiğim için o biraz önce
söylediği her Pazar o programı yapıyorum.
Bir bıkkınlık, bir vazgeçmişlik, bir pes
etme hali, bir acayip yenilgi duygusu…
Olabilir mi böyle bir şey?
Hissedebilir miyiz?
Yapayalnız kalabilir miyiz?
Kendimizi, ruhumuzu, geleceğimizi,
hayallerimizi, umutlarımızı,
heyecanlarımızı, tutkularımızı
yenilgiye uğratabilir miyiz?
Ben Kapadokya’da doğdum.
Gittiniz mi bilmiyorum ama muazzam
bir coğrafya, çok farklı bir yer.
Can Yücel der ki…
Edebiyat mezunuyum, onun için şiire, söze,
kelimeye, ifadeye hep heyecanla yaklaşırım.
Edebiyatı severim.
İsteyerek, bilinçle bana katkı yapacağını
fark ettiğim ve özümsediğim için
edebiyata doğru yöneldim.
Çalışırken okudum.
Ve muazzam bir sözü var Can Yücel’in:
“Toprak gibi olmalısın,
ezildikçe sertleşmelisin.”
Kapadokya’da büyürken,
9 yaşına kadar o topraklara basarken,
dedemin bana uzattığı çavuş üzümünü
yerken, her bağbozumunda toprakta
alın teri döken insanları seyrederken
elbette bir değişime uğramışımdır.
Bir şey kalmıştır, bir tortu vardır.
Evde demokrasi konuşuldu hep.
Babam bir hukuk aşığıydı,
bir hukuk adamıydı.
Muazzam bir karakterdi.
Evde demokrasi konuşuldu,
evde başkasının hakkını yeme,
sakın başkasının hakkını çiğneme,
sakın haksız kazanma diye
sürekli ama sürekli farkına
varmadan bizi eğitti.
Müthiş bir annenin çocuğuyum.
Onurlu, gururlu, her zaman doğruyu
söyleyen, hiçbir zaman doğrudan şaşmayan,
haksız ben bile olsam
beni ezmekten çekinmeyen
çok karakterli bir kadının çocuğuyum.
Muhtemelen aranızda.
Ve bu programı yaparken bir gazeteci
olarak, bir insan olarak,
bir birey olarak, bir Cumhuriyet çocuğu
olarak kendime hep şunu söylüyorum
her programda, her başlangıçta,
her kamera dokunuşunda.
Kendime diyorum ki:
Bu topraklara bir borcun var.
Kapadokya o kadar farklı bir yer ki.
Yani volkanik kayaların
oluşturduğu bir hayal dünyası.
İçimde her zaman o muhteşem coğrafyayı
seyrederken keşfetme duygusu,
daha iyisini yapma duygusu,
dehlizlerden çıkma duygusu,
mağaralara girip karanlıktan
korkmama duygusu…
Karanlıktan korkmayın, dimdik durun.
O duyguyu bana Kapadokya verdi.
Ama ben nereden geldiğimi biliyorum.
Hangi toprağa bastığımı,
hangi topraktan çıktığımı,
nereye yürüdüğümü yaşamım boyunca
keşfederek yavaş yavaş öğrendim.
Ama beslendiğim yer çok iyi.
Önce aile!
Başarı kazanmak istiyorsanız,
hayatta bir fark yaratmak istiyorsanız…
Bütün bu salonu sabahtan itibaren
doldurdunuz, para verdiniz.
Para harcadınız, emek harcadınız,
geldiniz ve manalı
bir şey görmek istiyorsunuz.
O manalı şey ne biliyor musunuz?
Kendinizsiniz!
“Bir seçim yapın, bir fark yaratın,
hayatın bir kenarından tutun”
demeye geldim ben buraya.
Hiç hazırlık yapmam, hiç prova yapmam,
ben hep buradan -kalbimden- konuşurum.
Ama akıl eğer burayla -kalple-
birleşmezse söylediğim her şey boş.
Bana inanmazsınız zaten.
Tribünlere oynuyor bu,
tiyatro yapıyor dersiniz.
“Edebiyat” yapıyor dersiniz.
Ben bir şey başarmaya çalışıyorum.
Bir heyecanı yükseltmek istiyorum.
Bir resim çizmek istiyorum.
Ben başarabilirim duygusunu verirken
aynı zamanda bir eleştiri yapıyorum.
Evet bıkkınız, evet yılgınız,
evet korkuyoruz,
evet gelecekten endişelerimiz var,
evet hayat beyaz değil.
Ne yaptın?
Bunu değiştirmek için, ne yaptın?
Sabah kalktığında, sabah kalktığın
andan itibaren neye karar verdin?
Her gün, her dakika, her saat…
Gün değişirken, aylar geçerken,
mevsimler değişirken,
yıllar birbirini takip ederken…
Yoksa aynı günleri yaşamış olmayalım?
Kendimize bir yalan söylemeyelim?
Hep eleştiriyoruz, hep tribünlerden
sahnelenen oyunu seyrediyoruz.
Biz ne yapıyoruz?
Biz ne yapıyoruz, arkadaşlar?
Kendinize sorun,
“Sabah kalktığımda bunu değiştirmek için
ben ne yaptım?” diye kendinize sorun.
Hayatlarımız çok değerli çünkü,
çok kıymetli ve çok kısa.
Bu kısa hayatın içinde anlamlı
bir şey yapmamız lazım.
Muazzam bir ülkede yaşıyoruz.
Ben bu ülkenin hikayesini anlatıyorum ama
üretimle kalkınabileceğini anlatıyorum.
Anadolu’dan beslendiğim için küresele
bakıyorum, bütün dünyayı görüyorum
ve bir dünya vatandaşı olmak istiyorum.
Ama yerel değerlerimi kaybetmeden
bir hikaye anlatıyorum.
Bu bir Alaska Kurbağası, ağaç kurbağası.
Kışın donuyor, sert kış
geldiğinde donuyor.
Ve kalbi de duruyor, o kadar az
çalışıyor ki fark edilmiyor bile.
Hiç kıpırdamıyor.
Donduğu için sağa sola bakamıyor bile
Sonra bahar geliyor ve neşe içinde
zıplamaya devam ediyor.
Her şey çözülüyor, her şey bitiyor.
Biz donduk, gençlik!
Donduk!
Sadece seyrediyoruz, sadece bakıyoruz,
sadece yorumluyoruz,
sadece tırnak içinde
yine "ahkam" kesiyoruz.
Ben de dahil.
Ama bir şey yapmamız lazım,
ne yapacağız?
Odaklanmamız lazım.
Neye odaklanacağız?
Bir seçim yapmamız lazım.
Neyi istemediğimizi bilmiyoruz.
Neyi istediğinizi biliyorsunuz.
Sizler, yukardakiler, en yukardakiler;
ne istediğinizi biliyorsunuz
ne istemediğinizi bilmiyorsunuz.
Önce onu ayıklayın.
Hayatınızda neyi görmek istemiyorsanız
önce onu ayıklayın.
Ben cumhuriyet çocuğuyum dedim ya,
gururla bakıyorum şu resme.
İnanılmaz bir tutku, dünyada başka
hiçbir oluşum hiçbir olay yok
cumhuriyet kadar özel.
Bir cevap, bir tutku, bir heyecan,
bir plan, bir umut,
belki bu model tutar diye
toprağa ekilmiş bir tohum cumhuriyet.
Biz onun çocukları olarak onu korumak,
yüceltmek, zenginleştirmek,
güçlendirmek için kendi adımıza ne yaptık?
Bu Kayseri’de, 1930’da
bir uçak fabrikası.
Bozkırın ortası.
Hiçbir şey yok, hiç kimse yok.
Herkes yılgın, herkes yorgun,
herkes bıkkın..
Ama nasıl bir beyazlık var
nasıl müthiş bir tutku var.
Uçak fabrikası ve motoru...
“Ben uçağı üretirim, motorunu
satarım” diyor.
Şu heyecana bir bakar mısınız?
Dünyanın hiçbir yerinde böyle
heyecan verici bir dönem yok.
Bir cevap, Ortadoğu’da tek başına
ayağa kalkabilecek bir dürtü,
bir güven, bir özgüven!
Muazzam bir kurgu, eğitim, bilim, sanat,
teknoloji, yüksek teknoloji,
insan hakları, evrensel hukuk, gençlik,
kadın, kadın, kadın!
Kadın var içinde, kadın
yükseltir bir ülkeyi.
Cesaretli olanı kadın verir.
Bakın ben bir annenin çocuğuyum dedim.
Asla başarmadan dönme diyen
bir annenin çocuğuyum.
Şu resme lütfen bakın:
1930, bozkırın ortasında…
Siz şimdi kendinizi yorgun, kırgın,
bıkkın, yenilmiş hissediyorsunuz değil mi?
Bir daha bakın, dönün dönün bakın.
Ben o mavi gözlü adama aşığım.
Arkadaşlar muhteşem bir lider,
muhteşem bir hayalperest.
Bize hep hayalperest olmanın
kötü bir şey olduğu öğretildi.
Hayal kurma, hayalci olma,
Polyanna gibi bakma dendi.
Hayal kuralım hep beraber,
ben o programı onun için yapıyorum.
Hayal kuralım diye,
bir heyecan olsun diye.
Belki içinizde bu konuşma bittikten sonra
ben ne yapabilirim diye bir umut
uyandırırım, belki bir heyecan doğar,
belki yarın sabah ben ne yapabilirim…
Üye olun bir siyasi partiye,
politikacı olmak zorunda değilsiniz.
İstemediğiniz,
görmek istemediğiniz,
yaşamak istemediğiniz şeyler varsa
değiştirmek istediğiniz…
Ama bunun bir parçası olun,
bir yere üye olun.
Sadece seçim zamanlarında gidip oy verin.
Kim ama kim seçilecekse, siz karar verin.
Üye olun bir sivil toplum kuruluşuna
ne olursa olsun, hangisi olursa olsun…
Ama sabah yatağınızdan kalktığınızda…
O komfor, o biraz önce dinlediğiniz komfor
Benim de söylemem lazım onu,
sıcak yataktan çıkmak çok zor çok
O kararı vermek.
Çok güzel çünkü, çok keyifli...
Beş dakika daha…
Şu anda karar verin, ne yapacağınıza.
Beni dinlerken.
Ben bunun bir parçası olabilirim diye
özgüven duyarak bir şeye karar verin.
İstemediğiniz her şeyi çıkarın.
Bir sivil toplum örgütü biliyor musunuz?
İsmi çok böyle ezberlenmiş gibi bir şey
gelebilir hepinize.
Ama hayır, bir neden.
Lösemili çocuklar için mi,
otizmli çocuklar için mi,
cumhuriyet yaşasın diye mi,
yeni uçak fabrikaları kuralım diye mi?
Ama bir hayaliniz olsun,
bir tutkunuz olsun.
Cumhuriyetin ne olduğunu anlayın,
Cumhuriyet tek başına tek kelimeyle
özetlenebilir: Bir hayal.
Hayal kurun.
Onun parçası olduğum için çok gururluyum.
Sürekli sürekli geriye bakıyorum,
başka ülkelere bakıyorum.
28 tane Avrupa Birliği ülkesine bakıyorum,
160 bin mülteciyi kapısında kabul etmeyen.
Evrensel demokrasi, insan hakları, hukuk,
her şeyin üstünde insan diyen
Avrupa Birliği’ne bakıyorum.
28 Avrupa Birliği ülkesi bir araya gelip
160 bin mülteciyi istemedi.
Kapı çat diye kapandı,
herkes dondu.
Nasıl olur?
380 milyon nüfusun içine
160 bin insan sığmaz mı?
“İnsan”la “insan olmak”la "insanoğlu olmak"
arasında çok büyük bir fark var arkadaşlar.
Cumhuriyet bize onu hissettirdi.
Zaman zaman unutabiliriz, zaman zaman
kavramlar karşısında birazcık
karamsarlığa bürünüp bildiklerimizi unutabiliriz.
Ama başka bir şey var,
şu resmin içinde başka bir şey var.
Defalarca bakın, bunun gibi yüzlercesi var
ama ben bunu çok seviyorum.
Çünkü bozkırın ortasında
bir umut, güneş doğuyor.
Bir umut, bu çocuklara…
Siz köy enstitülerinin,
ailelerinin torunlarısınız.
Köy enstitülerinden mezun olan
çocukların torunlarısınız.
Tek tek tuğlayla okul inşa ediyorlar,
hiçbir şey yok.
Koşarak gidiyorlar öğrenmek için.
Bilim, teknoloji, sanat, Shakespeare ile
birlikte kooperatifçiliği öğrenmek için.
Kimseye muhtaç olmayayayım diye Atatürk
Orman Çiftliği’nde bitki, enerji bitkisi
eken cumhuriyetin heyecanına
ortak olmak için.
Ortadoğu’nun kanlı petrol batağına
girmeyeyim diye hayaller kuran,
enerji bitkisi eken ondan sonra da
bütün çiftçilere parasız dağıtan
cumhuriyetin o şahane
tutkusuna ortak olmak için.
Bir heyecan, bir beklenti, bir umut…
Eğitim sistemine bakın.
Bunu özellikle getirdim size.
5. sıradaki Çin, adını yazamıyor bile
oradaki Çin aslında Tayvan.
Çünkü Tayvan tanınmayan bir ülke.
Kimse tanımıyor, kimse bilmiyor,
Birleşmiş Milletler sen
bir ülke değilsin diyor.
Uluslararası havalimanına
uçaklar inemiyor.
Bir karar vermiş, teknolojiye
yatırım yapacağım ve çocuklara.
Bakın PISA testi OECD ülkeleri arasında yapılan…
Programlarımda sürekli söylerim, biz hep
söyleriz kendi programlarımızda çünkü
bir hayalimiz, bir inancımız anlatacağımız
bir tutkumuz ve hikayemiz var.
Bu eğitim, eğitim olmazsa
hiçbir şey yok.
Burada Taipei denilen yer aslında
Tayvan, her sene ilk beşte.
Teknoloji oradan çıkıyor, bilim oradan
çıkıyor, algoritma oradan çıkıyor.
Donanım, yazılım oradan çıkıyor.
Cebinizdeki,
ister Güney Koreli olsun
ister Amerikan olsun fark etmez,
telefonların en az %80’inin
donanımı oradan çıkıyor.
İsrail’e gittim geçen gün.
Niye gittim biliyor musunuz?
Bir günde randevu aldım.
15 milyar dolara bir şirket satıldı,
çünkü sıradan bir araba içine küçücük bir
mikroçip yerleştirildikten sonra,
beni otobanda tek başına insansız
200 km, hız yaparak götürdü.
Yan tarafta oturdum, şoförü yoktu.
Mikroçip; akıl demek, bilim demek,
zeka demek, insan hayali demek.
4. sanayi devrimini yaşıyoruz şu an
ve hepinizin çok büyük şansları var.
Bir fikrin varsa, bir aklın varsa;
korkmadan, yılmadan,
bana kızarlar, annem kızar, patronum
karar vermez demeden…
Maaşının zamlı mı olmasını istiyorsun?
Gelecek ay zamlı maaş mı, çal kapıyı!
Bir projen mi var çık karşısına
Ama konuş, ama erteleme.
Erteleme, şu andan itibaren
karar ver korkusuzca.
Bakın Türkiye 44. Sırada,
bunu eleştirmiyorum.
Türk çocukları aptal değil çünkü,
sistemin kendisi aptal.
Bizim eğitim sistemimiz;
tamamen fabrikasyon, tamamen birbirine
benzeyen, aynı düşünen, aynı giyinen,
aynı müzikten hoşlanan, aynı hayata bakan,
aynı cümleleri kuran arka arkaya…
Tutkularını, umutlarını,
heyecanlarını yitirmiş;
sorgulamayan, zekasını kullanmayan, daha
fazla işleri karıştırmayan,
icat çıkarmayan gençler yetiştiriyor.
Yıkın bunu, yıkın bu duvarı.
Bu aptal sistemi asla kabul etmeyin.
Okulda ne alıyorsanız alın ama
boğulun kitaplara, internete girin.
Farklı şeyler,
sizi zenginleştirecek şeyler…
Sonra bir araya gelmeliyiz,
bir arada olmalıyız.
Bu iletişim çağında darmadağınık olmaz.
Tayvan bunu başarıyor.
Arkasında o var, şu var,
bu var, sermaye var…
Hayır! Bir hayal var.
İnsana yatırım var; matematik öğreniyor,
fen öğreniyor ve her seferinde
o eğitim kalitesiyle ilk 5’e giriyor.
44. olan Türkiye’nin ilk 3’e girmesi
tamamen bir anlık karardır.
Ona buna değil insana yatırım,
eğitime yatırımdır.
Bakın tüm iş yerlerimizdeki,
Bu çok küçük bir şey, göremeyebilirsini
ama hemen özetleyeyim.
OECD ülkeleri bir araştırma yapmış.
Sadece orta dereceli okullarda
değil arkadaşlar,
bakın bu listenin en altında Türkiye var.
Bu liste; OECD ülkeleri arasında
beyaz yaka yani eğitimini almış,
şirketlere girmiş
ama matematikte sonuncu sırada.
Neden biliyor musunuz,
çünkü işletmelerdeki 5583 denek demiş ki
“Ben bilgisayar kullanmayı bilmiyorum.”
Bunu değiştirelim,
hadi değiştirelim.
Gidin Bağcılar’ın sokaklarına, girin
Esenler’in sokaklarına, Sultanbeyli’ye…
Robert Koleji’nden mezun olan çocuk,
imam-hatiplilerle buluşsun.
Dünyanın en büyük gelirine sahip,
Türkiye’nin en zengin
ailelerinin çocukları gerçekten
Bağcılar’daki fakir çocuklarla buluşsun.
Ama dokunsun, ona bir hayal anlatsın.
Bir tutku, bir coşku…
Bir cumartesi sabahı kalkın girin
sokaklara, girin dokunun,
sizin varlığınızın farkına varsın.
Böyle bir insan var desin; bana geldi beni
elledi, dokundu, bana önem verdi desin.
Bir ara sokakta yürüsenize,
şansı olmayan çocuklarla.
Apayrıyız, bambaşka yerlerde duruyoruz.
Biz daha şanslıyız,
sizler daha şanslısınız,
para verip buraya gelebildiniz.
Bunu dinlemek isteyen kim bilir Van’da,
Yozgat’ta, Kayseri’de, Artvin’de,
Trabzon’da, Edirne’de insanlar var.
Birileri bir yerlerde bir şeyler yapmak
istiyor, farkında değiliz onlara dokunalım
Yüksek teknoloji ihracatımız
bakın, nereden nereye.
Çin, 560 milyar dolar yaparken Türkiye 2.2
Nasıl yapacak bu eğitimle?
Yetinmeyin, aptal yetiştiren
sistemi gerçekten yıkın.
Farklı kurslara gidin,
farklı yerlerden öğrenin,
farklı insanlarla tanışın ama
bir şeyi başarmak, kendinize
bir şey eklemek için bir tutkunuz
bir hayaliniz olsun.
Bu bir fabrika, Çin’den bir fotoğraf.
Benzeri Almanya’da da var.
İnsan yok, robotlar çalışacak artık,
insan yok.
Biz bu dünyayı yakalamalıyız,
tutkuyla yakalanır bu heyecanla.
Cumhuriyetin bize verdiği heyecanla
Bakın bütün petrol şirketleri,
Ortadoğu’yu kana bulayan
bütün petrol şirketleri bitmiş.
On yıl içinde neler değişmiş,
artık sadece teknoloji şirketleri var.
Biz nerede adımızı yazdırıyoruz?
1930’daki, uçak fabrikası
kuran Türkiye nerede?
Bu bir geçmiş özlem mi, geçmişte
yaşama arzusu mu? Hayır.
Biz çok şanslıyız, başka hiçbir ülkeye,
hiçbir millete, hiçbir gence
ait olmayan bir mirası devralmışsınız.
Bir kez bir umut mirası var elinizde;
onu harcamayın, yok saymayın.
Neye sahip olduğumuzu bilirsek,
gücü oradan yükseltiriz.
Eğitime bakar mısınız, üst gelir grubu
oldukça, insanlar para kazandıkça,
çocuklarına hayal yatırımı yapıyorlar:
%64,7. Alt gelir grubu %2,2 iken.
Türkiye zenginleşiyor ama
eğitime yatırım yapıyor
Ama bu eğitim bizi bizden uzaklaştıracak
bir eğitimse gerçekten yaratıcı,
sorgulayıcı, cesaretli, onurlu, ahlaklı…
Ahlak en büyük sorunumuz.
Gerçekten dürüstlük ve kendine dürüstlük.
Eğer bu eğitim bunları vermiyorsa;
matematiği, feni, teknolojiyi geçiyorum.
Ama ahlaklı, tutkulu, hedefi olan,
ilerleme heyecanı duyan bir gençlik
yetiştirmiyorsa bunu siz yapacaksınız;
fark edeceksiniz.
Bakın cep telefonları yüzünden
kimse kimsenin yüzüne bakmıyor diyoruz.
Eskiden de buymuş işte, herkes gazetelerde
kimse kimsenin yüzüne bakmıyor.
Bir Rosa Parks var, bütün Amerika’da
bütün zencilerin tamamına
otobüslere binme yasağı,
marketlere girme yasağı,
sokakların sağ tarafında zenciler
sol tarafında beyazlar yürüyecek diye
bir Amerika varken
tek başına ayağa kalktı.
Otobüste arkaya oturmayacağım dedi.
“Zenci arkaya oturacak”
Arkaya oturmayacağım ve ben öne gidip
oturacağım yoksa ayakta gidiyorum dedi.
Bütün Amerika ayağa kalktı, sonra ne oldu?
Eşiktlik, insan hakları, evrensel
demokrasiyi, tek bir kadın oraya getirdi.
Bir hayal çünkü, şahane bir hayal,
güzel bir hayal.
Bu Bruna Castano’nun
muhteşem bir bronz heykeli.
Her şeyiniz olabilir, yola çıkabilirsiniz
ama şurayı unutmayın lütfen.
Orası tutku, orası ruhumuz,
orası benliğimiz,
orası göğsümüzün içi, kalbimiz orası.
İçi boş olmasın böyle,
bu parçayı doldurun.
Ve şu köpeği hatırlayın, bir bomba
saldırısı sırasında ona bakan önüne ekmek
birazcık da su koyan bekçiyi hayatını
kaybettiğinde günlerce bekleyen şu köpek.
Benim için Türkiye’yi
yükselten fotoğraftır.
Bu köpeğin sahip olduğu inanca, tutkuya,
bağlılığa, sevgiye, yüksek ahlaka
hepimiz sahip olalım.
“Sürüklenirsek hiçiz, dayanırsak varız.”
Çok teşekkürler.
(Alkış)